monsieur luc chatel pour le groupe
monsieur le premier ministre
semaine après semaine vous l'avez encore
fait il ya quelques minutes vous vous
indignez dans cet hémicycle en vous
référant aux valeurs de la république
alors je vais vous donner l'occasion
monsieur le premier ministre de mettre
en concordance vos paroles et vos actes
en vous posant trois questions la
première concerne l'égalité de
traitement des justiciables
pouvez-vous nous garantir monsieur le
premier ministre que dans la sphère dit
d'air cocaïne
tous les clients de la compagnie
aérienne mis en cause ont été traités de
la même manière c'est à dire qu'ils ont
vu pendant plusieurs mois leurs
facturations détaillées étudier et leur
géolocalisation activée j'imagine que
vous êtes sensible aux principes
d'égalité de traitement
la deuxième question concerne l'accès
des droits à la défense
est ce que monsieur le premier ministre
comme la loi le prévoit
le bâtonnier de paris a été informé qu
ont étudié les fadettes d'un avocat au
barreau de paris
nicolas sarkozy je vous pose la question
la troisième question monsieur le
premier ministre concerne l'indépendance
de la justice et la séparation des
pouvoirs
monsieur le premier ministre votre garde
des sceaux a indiqué dimanche qu'elle
était informée par un rapport du
procureur général de cette enquête que
savait tels que saviez vous monsieur le
premier ministre de la géolocalisation
du chef de l'opposition
que savait le président de la république
de la géolocalisation du chef de
l'opposition
dans quelle démocratie vivons nous alors
les français se posent ces questions
monsieur le premier ministre nous
attendons vos réponses parce que cette
affaire pourrait très vite devenir une
affaire d'état
c'est monsieur chatel la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre sur le
député monsieur le ministre chatel
un peu de calme s'il vous plaît
interrogé sur une enquête judiciaire en
cours et vous connaissez parfaitement la
réponse du gouvernement
elle est d'ailleurs inlassablement
répétée par la garde des sceaux en ce
moment retenu au sénat par la défense de
son projet de loi sur la réforme de la
justice
et cette réponse n'a pas changé et
monsieur chatel sous ce quinquennat elle
ne changera pas nous n'intervenons pas
dans les affaires individuelles ne
donnons aucune instruction et laissons
au parquet le soin d'apprécier
l'opportunité d'informer ou non la
chancellerie avec discernement et
rigueur
alors bien entendu monsieur le député et
c'est heureux
le parquet général d'aix en provence a
jugé opportun de signaler la sphère dit
air cocaïne aux services de la
chancellerie en raison de sa gravité de
sa complexité et de sa dimension
internationale et le parquet général a
agi comme leurs effets tout autre
parquet général c'est ainsi que la garde
des sceaux est tenu informé des
évolutions les plus importantes des
affaires les plus graves est seulement
de cela
ce qui change considérablement monsieur
le député par rapport à la pratique
observée sous l'ancien quinquennat
le nombre d'affaires suivi par la
direction des affaires criminelles et
des grâces a considérablement baissé
d'environ 13 milles en 2012 à 5690 au 30
septembre dernier monsieur le député
bien que la sphère dit air cocaïne était
suivi par les services de la
chancellerie il s'avère en revanche que
les actes décidés par le juge
d'instruction de marseille est relatif à
monsieur nicolas sarkozy dans la sphère
dit air cocaïne ne peut en aucun cas été
portée à la connaissance du ministère de
la justice par le parquet général
d'aix-en-provence et c'est logique
si vous voulez bien m'écouter puisque on
pose des questions puisque ces actes
n'ont manifestement pas apporté
d'éléments de nature à permettre à
l'enquêté de progresser pour le reste
monsieur le député
mesdames et messieurs les députés de
l'opposition il n'appartient pas au
pouvoir exécutif de commenter les
mesures judiciaires en cours ni de se
prononcer sur l'opportunité des actes
accomplis pour ce faire je me permets de
vous le rappeler il y à des procédures
des institutions des voies de recours
la justice est indépendante je vous le
rappelle est tout à l'heure
même si vous leur mettez en cause et
j'entends à la place qui est la mienne
qu'elle puisse poursuivre ses missions
en toute sérénité sans aucune
intervention ni pression ni les versions
de quelque nature qu'elles soient
il en va je le dis tout à l'heure de
l'autorité de l'état
mais manifestement quand il s'agit de la
restauration de l'ordre républicain et
de l'autorité de l'état
vous ne retenez que le premier mot merci
monsieur le premier ministre apparaît
comme un homme sage pour le